aujourd'hui, en l'absence d'une police totale, je pense
qu'il y a une raison pour laquelle Alice est
là depuis si longtemps,
c'est quelque chose qui est un classique et
c'est pourquoi vous vous sentez à l'aise d'en
faire une interprétation différente, il
y a une certaine liberté à ce sujet,
je jure que tous les Teddy's Timmy sont
tellement très  des idées particulières sur la façon dont
ce monde ne devrait pas être c'était
merveilleux de revenir dans un
monde d'imagination sans limites tim a
établi le look d'Underland un
sentiment que la langue c'était comme dire
bonjour à un vieil ami vous pouvez vraiment aller
au-delà de ce que vous  'ai fait avant de
revenir à travers le miroir pour rouvrir
la relation entre le Chapelier et
Pallas nous avons vu un professeur une victime qui
jeune radis pourtant c'était une
expérience fantastique Alice est un grand personnage
elle est vraiment sa propre personne et
pas mal  plus confiant dans ce film, c'est
agréable de jouer quelqu'un comme ça, c'est une
histoire très émouvante et c'est très
ancré dans les relations, même s'il
a une grande fa  un arrière-plan fantastique pour moi,
les éléments visuels de celui-ci font partie de
l'histoire et permettent d'explorer ces vrais
thèmes, mais d'une manière plus fantaisiste, l'
évêque qui devient bon avec ce bâtiment
que j'aime quand un artiste a un timbre
et Tim Burton est l'un de ceux  les artistes
Tim embrassent ce monde psychédélique
qui est le style d'appel durable qu'il ajoute
et une sensibilité à ce sujet
une réalisation si fantastique que vous avez un
regard, vous savez que c'est comme burton-esque est
une chose incroyable
Oh Junko, laissez-moi